foreign
you and nine other individuals have been
captured by super intelligent alien
overlords the aliens think humans look
quite tasty but their civilization
forbids eating highly logical and
Cooperative beings
unfortunately they're not sure whether
you qualify so they decide to give you
all a test
through its Universal translator the
alien guarding you tells you the
following you will be placed in a single
file line facing forward in size order
so that each of you can see everyone
lined up ahead of you you will not be
able to look behind you or step out of
line
each of you will have either a black or
a white hat on your head assigned
randomly and I won't tell you how many
of each color there are
when I say to begin each of you must
guess the color of your hat starting
with the person in the back and moving
up the line and don't even try saying
words other than black or white or
signaling some other way like intonation
or volume you'll all be eaten
immediately if at least nine of you
guess correctly you'll all be spared you
have five minutes to discuss
can you think of a strategy guaranteed
to save everyone
the key is that the person at the back
of the line who can see everyone else's
hats can use the words black or white to
communicate some coded information
so what meaning can be assigned to those
words that will allow everyone else to
deduce their hat colors
it can't be the total number of black or
white hats there are more than two
possible values but what does have two
possible values is that number's parity
that is whether it's odd or even so the
solution is to agree that whoever goes
first will for example say black if he
sees an odd number of black hats and
white if he sees an even number of black
hats let's see how it would play out if
the hats were distributed like this the
tallest captive sees three black hats in
front of him so he says black telling
everyone else he sees an odd number of
black hats he gets his own hat color
wrong but that's okay since you're
collectively allowed to have one wrong
answer
prisoner 2 also sees an odd number of
black hats so she knows hers is white
and answers correctly prisoner 3 sees an
even number of black hats so he knows
that his must be one of the black hats
the first two prisoners saw prisoner 4
hears that and knows that she should be
looking for an even number of black hats
since one was behind her but she only
sees one so she deduces that her hat is
also black prisoners five through nine
are each looking for an odd number of
black hats which they see so they figure
out that their hats are white now it all
comes down to you at the front of the
line if the ninth prisoner saw an odd
number of black hats that can only mean
one thing
you'll find that this strategy works for
any possible arrangement of the hats the
first prisoner has a 50 chance of giving
a wrong answer about his own hat but the
parody information he conveys allows
everyone else to guess theirs with
absolute certainty
Begins by expecting to see an odd or
even number of hats of the specified
color if what they count doesn't match
that means their own hat is that color
and every time this happens the next
person in line will switch the parity
they expect to see so that's it you're
free to go it looks like these aliens
will have to go hungry or find some less
logical organisms to abduct